hi Rashida it's Phil how are you I'm I'm
good I'm so excited to be able to talk
to you today
um and thank you for taking this time
too thank you for having me I appreciate
it of course of course so I want to jump
right in
um I would say that you are the queen of
the snap era in hip-hop is that
something you'd agree with
I would say
um I wouldn't say queen of snap but what
I would say is
um I've definitely been a part of
several eras of hip-hop from crunk music
to snap music to you know the
underground ATL queen of Kronk slash
Georgia Peach slash boss chick yes
absolutely absolutely you know my my
sister went to college in Atlanta and so
she was all she was there that she was
there living it and she was in the
moment she was in the moment in the turn
up moment exactly exactly and so I I was
a part of it through a filter through
her period I love it I love it yeah so
so you started your rap career with the
Capers what made you decide to pursue
your solo career honestly with the
Capers you know we were all like sisters
and you know we had this we had a point
in time where you know we were doing our
group thing and then you know different
things started happening and you know
women wanting to go in different
directions but I just loved music and um
when you know when the group was
dismantling I had went to Kirk at that
time because we had been signed to him
and I've been signed to Kirk my whole
you know music career right and I went
to him and I said hey you know I know
you know the things aren't working out
with the group but I want to continue to
move forward and and do music and he was
like well I tell you what if you work
hard you focus you start writing all
your own music and doing everything and
show me you're serious I'll push you
push you push you until I can't push no
more and amazing still here
all right that's a good thing that's a
good thing so let's let's talk about the
boss mixtapes
um rock remix is like it I love it I
love it because I love the song so the
remix is like yeah
um so you've got Toya you've got Diamond
you've got Lola and Candy how did that
group come together you know what it was
just me calling I said Hey listen I want
to do the Bedrock memes because you know
during the time when I was doing like
the boss music like series I was
really like so focused on continuing to
put music out being an independent
artist being an underground artist you
know I was just on that Vibe of like
it's just I'm eating it I'm sleeping I
just got to do it but I also felt like
you know we have to Showcase and like
come together as women and make sure
that you know we're we're out here doing
our thing so when I decided I was like
you know what I want to remix the
Bedrock I said but let me call up a few
of the ladies to you know make sure that
we make this sexy and fun but also show
that the females can rock and it's
strength in numbers let's do it and it
it happened really good
I love it I love it
um so you've got the career the music
career the music is happening right and
then you decide to continue making these
money moves and you know open the Press
Boutique what inspired you to Open Press
okay so honestly I had been online
um prior to you know opening a physical
location
um and
like starting pressed in my dining room
and really loving it being able to do it
it's we've been online for 14 years so
this was before like everything and
everybody with all these different
boutiques and you know all the stuff
that you know about now
um it's something that I love I always
was just a girl who just like to you
know have fun with fashion I'm a Gemini
so I might wake up like a tomboy one day
a girly girl another day a day gone prom
dress and it ain't nobody prom around
[Music]
um but you know I just loved it and I
had been telling Kirk I was like man
listen we need to open
um you know we need to continue with the
online but you know we need to think
about opening a physical store and you
know him being the businessman he's like
you know we have to get to a certain
place before we do that because with
this online business we're doing
extremely well the overhead is really
low you know are we sure we want to step
into that rim and that's after us like
setting goals like I say to people all
the time you know we set goals and we
execute that after setting goals and we
set a mark on how many customers we
wanted to have prior to opening a
physical store and once we hit that
number we said okay we're gonna do it
and the rest is history we're still here
pressed yes thank goodness for that too
and there's I know there's now a
location in Houston why'd you choose
Houston as the first city outside of
Atlanta
well one thing about Houston is it
really kind of reminds me of Atlanta
um and I
we did a lot of research on just like
different malls different locations and
Houston is a very thriving City there's
a lot of money in Houston there's a lot
of diversity in Houston but the Galleria
in Houston is also one of the biggest
malls that brings in a lot of money
you know so after kind of like surfing
that mall for like a week sitting in the
hallways and people looking at us like
why is this curtain Rashida sitting here
watching everybody you know we're bag
watching seeing what people's buying and
what direction they're going in in this
mall after a while we decided to make
that you know the next the out of state
um location but I actually did close the
Houston location
um you know it was it was a a decision
that we had to make we're still in
Atlanta on 14th Street so we're on 296
14th Street in Atlanta and in Midtown so
come see us but yes it was just the
workers and it was just to nobody wanted
to do right so it's just like yeah you
gotta learn when the quarter plugs
I understand that so yes I mean is there
any chance of a Dallas location just
because you know I is that where you at
oh so what were you at yes yes and you
know pinky Cole just brought
vegan here so I mean
and you know honestly it was between
Dallas and Houston really yes initially
it was between the two then we decided
to go to Houston because of just like
all the research on the Galleria as well
and also that Galleria was is the same
as when we were previously at Phipps
Plaza the same Mall company which was
Simon so it was a great relationship
that we had built and going into the
Galleria was just it was just perfect
makes sense that makes sense well you
know just let me know when I will I keep
you posted
back to those the businesses
um you and your husband have also opened
a restaurant uh Frost Bistro and bar I
mean restaurants are notoriously
difficult to run so what made y'all want
to dive into that extremely difficult I
will say
um you know and with my husband being so
supportive of every single thing that
I've always wanted to do for music to
Fashion To Everything one of his main
goals was he wanted to have like a
lounge you know space
um and it took years of course he's
always like you know we did all these
things you know building press and all
that now it's about time now it's about
time now it's about time finally the
time came
um and it was a real estate move for us
as well as a business move and we just
decided to go for it dive in we didn't
have any experience on it at all
um but I really wouldn't want it any
other way because it allowed us to learn
every aspect about the restaurant
business and we actually have just
revamped
um and changed from The Nightlife to
breakfast and brunch so we strictly
serve breakfast and brunch and it's been
a really great journey so far but it is
a difficult business I will say oh yeah
well brunch is smart everybody loves
brunch everybody loves brunch in and out
and completely understand go home
exactly
exactly oh man so you know all of your
businesses they're rooted in Atlanta
obviously uh would you say that Atlanta
is the best city for black
entrepreneurship and if so why
well I can't speak for everybody
um but I will say for myself I feel as
though it's the it was the best moved
and has been the best move
um you know Atlanta has become this you
know this just Mecca you know initially
I've been here over 27 years but you
know initially coming down here it
wasn't the Atlanta that it is now but it
still had this feeling of wow like
this city is so full of us and
successful you know men and women of
color it makes it inspires you to want
to do something you know and so being
able to do that and see other people
like myself other women other families
other men you know everybody being
successful I'm like Hey listen this is
where it's at I don't want to do
anything else you know so for myself I
feel like yes Atlanta is a great great
great great City and you also get a
sense of you know of course not from the
very beginning but as things have kind
of transpired Through The Years you know
with friends and different people we all
Inspire each other that's why we all you
know stick together and try to support
each other the the best way that we can
because you know it's it's a beautiful
thing and like I always say is
strengthen numbers and it's room for
everybody so yeah absolutely absolutely
I love that now now let's get the boss
moves all right your show boss moves
it's focus on how you balance all of
your businesses in addition to being a
wife and a mother what is one thing that
you hope your viewers gain from watching
you and the experiences that you're
sharing
the
life lives like nothing's perfect you
know you you just try to do the best you
can you know you you learn from your
mistakes you fall you get back up you
don't always have the right answers you
wake up some days with the intentions on
Conquering the world and something comes
up and you're not able to conquer the
world that day you know so it's just you
know people understanding that you know
nothing's perfect but work hard let's go
after it let's uplift let's let's let's
pray together let's stay focused let's
try to help each other and that's really
what it is with boss moves I want people
to be able to take away that you know
it's not always easy and not always
perfect but if someone can give you
something or drop some gems for you or
you you're able to see something that
you know triggers you to be like you
know what let me get back focused
because Rasheeda said or was that girl
did this or this happened you know I
feel like I'm winning if that happens
yeah absolutely and it's that's so
important especially now in like the
social media era where everybody is
projecting Perfection and that's just
not realistic it's not it's not and it
drives me crazy because like you know
people always you know it's just like
you know the movie just having the most
amazing ending and you see that and you
like yeah and then when you go to the
top of the movie you like dang they went
through all that to get to that
beautiful ending like yeah that's what
it is but yeah absolutely like I I love
being able to do all these different
things and people see this on Boss mode
so yeah absolutely that's so cool and I
it's so appreciative of that because it
is important
um so what can we look forward to in
season two of Boss moves well season two
um I'm super excited August 15th so make
sure y'all got Philo don't forget
um season two Okay so it's a little
switch up because we kind of dig into
other people's business and be able to
get a lot of information and gems from
them
um and not only do we do that so we'll
have a little tea a little fun little
inspiration but we also um on this
season you know I'm mentoring young
ladies who have businesses that didn't
quite work like they wanted them to or
businesses that are kind of like failing
and we're going in trying to like revamp
restructure get them on the right path
um and then you know we're also like
um dealing um with women and
self-confidence and young lady um it's a
young lady on the show who had gastric
bypass and you know she's trying to get
you know herself back you know sexy fun
and lit and you know sometimes that's a
really hard process for people
um so you know being able to like share
that and you know kind of dig into that
is a great thing and then you know we're
talking about you know girlfriend
conversations you know having your
strong friends and make ensure that you
know you're checking on each other and
being there because your circle is
really important and lastly of course
love and business child trying to you
know hold it together as husband and
wife we have these businesses you know
and just life together and family and
you know how that whole dynamic works so
it's a lot yeah you gotta make time for
that too it's hard to but you gotta yes
awesome so my last you know question
you've got to ask about love and hip hop
you know you've been a staple on Love
and Hip Hop Atlanta you know pretty much
since the series began do you see your
time on that show coming to an end
anytime soon or well I would definitely
say you know all good things come to an
end at some time you know and um I do
think that um you know it's it's it's
getting close
um you know the game is changing too a
lot you know reality television game and
stuff like that so one thing I will say
though is you know stepping into Love
and Hip Hop Atlanta initially not
realizing it will become like a cultural
phenomenon being able to be a part of
that has been nothing but a blessing for
us you know and you have and it's a give
and take you got to take the good with
the bad so this is being a part of that
is one thing that has been nothing but a
complete blessing and so whenever that
light does dim I can probably sleep well
to say I feel like I did a pretty decent
job
with the platform so I can't be mad
absolutely no yeah that's that's it
that's true oh thank you so much
um I just want to give that other you
know reiterate boss moves season two
premieres August 15th on Philo yes
perfect thank you so much Rashida I hope
you have a wonderful day and thank you
again
thank you